Fox News meteorologist meteorologist
Adam klotz was writing the New York City
subway early Sunday when he saw an
elderly man getting pushed around by
teenagers when he tried to intervene the
young men beat him three of those teens
aged 15 to 17 were just released without
any charges by Manhattan's D.A Alvin
Bragg so frustrating Adam klotz is a fox
meteorologist he joins us tonight oh man
you look tough I am sorry what happened
I pulled this off all right right yeah
you pull it off quite well
um and you did it in the service of a
good deed but I'm shocked um what
happened I was on my way home from the
the Giants game I was watching it at a
bar with some friends so it's like 12 45
in the morning and the car was fairly
busy so it was not like some desolate
situation A group of I'd say like 17s
one started to light up a joint and with
the lighter still in his hand just put a
live lighter in an elderly man's hair
and it blew up like a matchbook come on
his entire head was on fire and the
guy's knocking out his and I was just
sitting right there watching it and how
can you not whoa guys you can't do that
and then they just did not want to be
told what they could or couldn't do so
then suddenly the focus was on me and
then you got a problem I said yeah you
can't do that and he's like try to stop
me and you know it just escalated and it
was a group of seven guys so I caught a
left a pretty good left kind of put my
head back into the wall another guy who
was just down off to my right it was
again a crowded car no one else said
anything other than hey you should get
off the car I actually moved to a whole
nother car on the on the train like at a
stop moved to another car we go a whole
nother stop the doors open I kind of
think it's over this whole group comes
and gang rushes me and jumps on me and
just starts beating me and kicking me I
hear put him to sleep put him to sleep
put him to sleep they wanted to knock me
out and my goal at that point is just
like cover my head because once you're
unconscious who knows what's going to
happen and I was able to avoid that but
I got kicked up and down the side kind
of stomped on I mean they they got their
licks in for sure so these guys lit an
old man on fire and then seven of them
beat you to the ground because they
didn't they didn't like that anyone had
anything to say like don't tell us what
we can and can't do
well you can see why Bernie gets cut off
um that's pretty unbelievable Adam Adam
klotz what a that's a shocking story and
I'm glad you're okay thank you around
thank you and thank you for doing that
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight